penny is such a hustler I love that her  comedy comes from all angles like she's  got a lot of good jokes she's quiet  crass before she is defiled because one  she is defiled she's like less special  direction and she has a lot of physical  comedy I love putting my body on the  line for comedy well I love you what I  realize is that you don't just do it the  one time that you see it in the film we  do it like hundreds of times the scene  which I kind of refer to as the trash  bag joke I had to do that so many times  to get the timing perfect yeah like  muscles by doing that crouching rebel is  very fluid with language likes to change  things a lot and improvise my sister  just one-off mother my kids actually  just saw their banana firm I still see  it against the maker of Danny's dead the  top of the park is raised  she's also really good with loosening  them up and changing what she's doing  and trying things and what about food  ooh there someone that if we do this  [Music]